-The saga of Tucker Carlson's
messy and abrupt exit
from Fox News
is still ongoing,
with yet more revelations
and speculation
about what exactly
led to his ouster.
The story is yet another example
of just how weak and fractured
the already unpopular
MAGA movement has become.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
After his abrupt and mysterious
dismissal from Fox News,
Tucker Carlson posted
what I guess was
some sort of proof-of-life video
on Twitter last night...
[ Laughter ]
...filmed from what I can
only assume is a secret lair
at the base of a volcano
or a fake doctor's office
from a low-budget porno.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, why are you
zooming in from your sauna?
That place looks like
the Unabomber's hideout
if he updated it
and put it on Airbnb.
[ Laughter ]
I also love the carefully
planted details
in the background,
like the globe.
Ooh! Ooh! A globe on a shelf!
It's like we're supposed
to think to ourselves,
"This mother[Bleep] is worldly!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, what is it with
these right-wing weirdos
filming incredibly
close-up videos
from their phony-looking
home studios?
Trump does the same thing now
with his stupid campaign videos.
You know, his Zach Galifianakis
rip-off between two flags.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Tucker never addressed
his ouster from Fox,
and most of what he said in the
video is utterly meaningless.
But he did end
on a somewhat unnerving note.
-When honest people
say what's true,
calmly and
without embarrassment,
they become powerful.
At the same time, the liars
who've been trying
to silence them
shrink and they become weaker.
That's the iron law
of the universe.
True things prevail.
Where can you still find
Americans saying true things?
There aren't many places left,
but there are some.
And that's enough.
As long as you
can hear the words,
there is hope.
See you soon.
-I'm impressed by
the confidence of a man
who went from filming
a top-rated TV show
in a flashy high-budget studio
to posting Twitter videos
from what I can only assume is
an episode
of "Tiny House Nation."
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he's auditioning
to be the new chief
on "Where in the World
Is Carmen Sandiego?"
[ Laughter ]
"Hello, gumshoes.
Can you spot Carmen Sandiego
in this peaceful protest?"
[ Laughter ]
Let's zoom in. There she is."
"Good work, gumshoes."
[ Laughter ]
Also, it's very --
it's very chilling
when a figure
as nefarious as Tucker
ends a self-taped video
from an undisclosed location
with the words "See you soon"
and then just disappears.
He should have pointed
to the globe when he said that.
"See you soon, Jakarta."
[ Laughter ]
That's how a jilted husband
ends a voicemail
in a Lifetime movie.
Next thing you know,
he's on your balcony
in a thunderstorm,
staring at you
through your window.
"Hello, darling, it's me.
I told you I'd see you soon.
[ Laughing maniacally ]
[ Laughter ]
But that's ridiculous.
This isn't actually
a Lifetime movie.
Tucker's never actually
started out his show
with some sinister
hypothetical like that.
-But, first tonight,
what if
your next-door neighbor
suddenly went dangerously insane
and started holding people
hostage in his house?
Would you consider
that threatening?
Would you even notice it?
-Jesus!
[ Laughter ]
That's how you start the show?!
How about a little ramp-up,
a couple jokes, or something?
He might as well have said,
"Good evening.
Look out behind you.
He's got a knife!"
[ Laughter ]
Why is he talking about a
hypothetical next-door neighbor
who suddenly goes insane?
He sounds like he's pitching
a dark reboot of "Seinfeld"
called "Breaking Kramer."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the difference is,
Kramer is not
the one who knocks.
-Hey.
[ Laughter ]
So, Sal wrote that
"not the one who knocks" joke.
And I read it,
and I didn't quite get it.
And he goes,
"You can cut it if you want."
And I'm like, "If I cut it,
how will you learn your lesson?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
But...
[ Laughter ]
By the way, if you're
curious what --
It was the absence of a laugh.
Did you notice that?
[ Laughter ]
By the way, if you're curious
what Tucker
was actually talking about
in that deranged hypothetical,
he was talking about Canada.
I swear I'm not making that up.
Here, watch.
-Those are not
theoretical questions.
Something very much like that
just happened
in our national neighborhood.
Canada...
-It's amazing that
the list of Tucker Carlson's
imagined enemies now includes
the entire nation of Canada.
And somehow that's not even
the weirdest thing on it.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Tucker posted
this weird little video
to, I guess, prove
that he still exists
after the network he worked for
essentially
disappeared him overnight.
So far, there's been
a lot of speculation
over what exactly
led to his exit,
but nothing concrete yet.
On the one hand,
the "L.A. Times" reported
that Tucker was pushed out
by Rupert Murdoch himself
and that Carlson's exit
is related
to a discrimination lawsuit
filed by Abby Grossberg,
a producer fired
by the network last month.
Meanwhile,
the "Wall Street Journal"
reported that Tucker Carlson's
vulgar, offensive messages
about his colleagues helped
seal his fate at Fox News.
And then "Vanity Fair" reported
yet another, stranger theory
that Tucker Carlson's
prayer talk
may have led
to his Fox News ouster,
with one source saying,
"That stuff freaks Rupert out."
And it wouldn't surprise me.
Rupert Murdoch definitely
seems like the kind of guy who,
even if he did go to church,
would play hardball
when the collection basket
comes around.
"I'm not giving you [Bleep]
a bloody cent
unless I get
VIP access to Heaven."
"Look, we can't we can't --
We can't guarantee VIP access.
We can tell Saint Peter
to expedite the entry process."
"Alright, alright,
here's a dollar.
Hold on,
I'm taking out 85 cents.
Don't move the basket,
ya [Bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
By the way, it also wouldn't
surprise me
if, when it comes to a guy
like Tucker Carlson,
there was, you know,
more than one reason
for getting [Bleep] canned.
Like, when they finally
nabbed Jeffrey Dahmer,
they weren't like,
"This is just for the last one."
And sure enough, last night,
"The New York Times"
reported new information
that Fox News board members
had discovered
even more vulgar text messages
that were so bad
they felt they needed
to sever ties with Tucker ASAP.
-Fox recently settled
a defamation lawsuit
with Dominion Voting Systems
for nearly $800 million
that alleged the network
repeatedly lied
about debunked
election-fraud claims.
Private texts and e-mails
from Carlson
emerged during the lawsuit,
including redacted messages
about Fox News executives.
-"The New York Times" reports
Carlson's redacted text messages
were even worse than ones
which were revealed
in those court filings.
And there was one message
that was particularly offensive,
which added to the concern
at the top of the company.
-Wow.
So, Fox put up with his racism,
bigotry, harassment, and
conspiracy theories for years.
But then they saw
this one text message
and said, "We got to get this
guy the [Bleep] outta here."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, what did
that text message say?
"I'll tell you what --
that Joe Biden
makes some good points"?
[ Laughter ]
If you zoom out from
the specifics of the Tucker saga
for a second,
there's a bigger story here.
The drama and infighting
that's now consumed the GOP,
Fox News, and the MAGA movement
is due in large part
to the fact that
their political project
has been an abject failure.
People don't want it.
They've lost in election
after election after election,
and their tactics
have caught up to them.
That's why they're trying
to turn the page
and pivot to guys
like Ron DeSantis.
But much like the rest
of the MAGA crowd,
DeSantis is so weird
and off-putting,
he's falling behind
in the polls.
Even his speaking cadence
is incredibly weird.
Just listen to him try
to deliver a normal speech.
-Republicans need to shake
the culture of losing
that has developed
in recent years.
The time for excuses is over.
-What is up with this dude?
He sounds like he's starring
in a middle-school production
of "Joseph and the Amazing
Technicolor Dreamcoat."
[ Stiffly ] Hello,
my name is Joseph,
and this is
my amazing new Dreamcoat.
It's just regular brown because
Technicolor has a gay agenda."
[ Laughter ]
DeSantis is so awkward
and uncharismatic,
he's somehow lagging behind an
even more off-putting weirdo --
the GOP front-runner/
current criminal defendant,
Donald Trump, who, in addition
to being under indictment,
Trump is also, as we've
documented many times before,
a weird man.
For example,
he was campaigning
recently in Florida,
where he stopped
at a pizza place
and offered his fans some pizza
in typically weird
Trump fashion.
-[ Chanting ] Trump! Trump!
Trump! Trump!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Jesus Christ.
[ Laughter ]
In 40 years,
the Republican Party
has gone from, "Mr. Gorbachev,
tear down this wall,"
to, "Does anyone want
a piece I've eaten?"
[ Laughter ]
No wonder Tucker Carlson is
hiding in a child's playhouse.
"Does anyone want
a piece I've eaten?"
Do you mean like, you'll
chew it up, digest it,
and then baby-bird it
into their mouths?
"Would anyone like
a soggy piece of pizza?
It's covered --
covered in my saliva
and has already been
premasticated by yours truly.
Masticated.
We love masticated, don't we?
It means "chewed,"
but it's a tricky word
because it sounds like
the other one.
Masticated -- it sound --
You know the one
I'm talking about, right?
The M-word.
We call it the M-word
because we don't like to say it
and we don't like to do it,
because if we do it,
we go blind."
"And our you-know-whats,
they..."
-Shrink and they become weaker.
[ Laughter ]
"My God, what is happening?
Hey!"
[ Laughter ]
That's our new -- I mean,
our new slang
for a video clip
that doesn't work is Kramered.
[ Laughter ]
Just like
the Dominion settlement
or the elections of 2018,
2020, and 2022,
the saga of Tucker Carlson's
fall from grace
is yet another example
of what happens
when the right-wing echo chamber
collides with reality.
It's a movement led by cruel,
malicious bullies
who think they're untouchable
and who lie to their audience
with contempt.
And now it's
catching up to them.
Every time Trump
and the MAGA crowd
think they've achieved peace
within the Republican Party,
it turns out it's...
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]